dort die probleme möchte ich auch gerne
mal haben die einer der top thema in der
esl er spielt dort starcraft 2 der
arbeit dann wenn andere freihaben haye
aber er kommt um die ganze welt also das
und noch viel mehr jetzt im talk mit
kuli okay ist die lage ja insgesamt ganz
gut
gestern schon hier jetzt bisschen
gezockt lief für einigermaßen gut das
heißt also gestern war die qualifikation
für die world cyber games da bin ich
zweiter geworden
du spielst ein bestimmtes spiel
starcraft 2 ist das genau das ein
echtzeitstrategiespiel kurz zur
erklärung man kann sich vorstellen wie
schach aber im gegensatz zum schacht
muss man mit dem reiter auch reiten und
mit den läufern hauptmann wanne agiert
richtig genau es kommt nicht nur darauf
an welche züge man macht dann auch wie
man die züge machen
es gibt auch diese messung im spiel
aperam action panels und so die schnelle
namen halt in wie 300 aktionen die die
an pro minute machen erst als schon eine
menge dann okay wie viel hast du ich bin
einer der langsameren profis ich hab
also vielleicht so 140 herum
okay wie schaffst du es dann auf platz
zwei er ist brandt nicht natürlich nicht
nur darauf an wie schnell man klickt
sondern man muss halt auch kollegen
freuen sich ja bald abermals schnell
gute entscheidung treffen können und das
ist halt so eine meiner stärken nicht
für die pure geschwindigkeit
man nennt sich ja auch den panzer
general genau die spieler also in
starcraft gibt es drei waffen darunter
ist eine die terraner sind für die
menschen und da kann man halt auch
damals auch eine einheit hat den tank
panzer und ich wurde altbekannt dadurch
sehr viele davon zu bauen
ich bin jetzt ein bisschen von dem
spielstil abgewichen aber so der
spitzname bleibt halt wie wird man denn
profi gamer wie kommt man dahin weil ich
weiß es gibt sehr viele leute die zu
hause
starcraft 2 spielen wie sieht das wasser
ist millionen seien jahr insgesamt hat
sich das spiel mehrere millionen mal
verkauft helge menge eine menge und wie
wird man profi gamer also hat sich halt
einfach so ergeben würde ich sagen ich
hab halt vor starcraft 2 schon sehr sehr
lange starke teams gespielt in starcraft
1 2 gab es halt noch keine große szene
dabei hin und wieder ein paar kleinere
events und dann als der kauf zweier aus
kamen sofort gewechselt und wurde als
relativ gut
und dann hat sich das halt so entwickelt
gesteigert es gab halt doch immer mehr
große events was hat das für ein
privatleben bedeutet was hattest du
bevor das passiert ist für pläne
und was hat sich jetzt geändert ja es
halt dann schon entweder so oder öfter
mal so dass man gerade am wochenende
dann viel zu tun hat da sind halt events
die großen turniere bei mir ist das
immer ein bisschen verdreht eigentlich
in die leute die normalen job haben
arbeiten habe ich halt eigentlich immer
frei okay in eine abends oder am
wochenende spielen dann manchmal schon
ein bisschen stressig und problematisch
man irgendwann das eigentlich hin will
was denkst du da manchmal ist es ist es
vielleicht ein weg der einen dahin
bringen wo man vielleicht nicht hin will
weil man nicht mehr das tun kann und
lassen kann was man will
oder ist es wirklich eine perspektive
wurde sagt egal das ist sowas
fantastisches das gleiche ist das wiegt
das auf alles wird schon sagen dass das
pferd also es macht sehr viel spaß man
kommt viel rum ich bin jetzt halt schon
mehrere male ich weiß schon usa da wäre
ich sonst wohl nie so einfach hin
gekommen und man erlebt viel findet auch
knüpft viele neue kontakte und freunde
also
es lohnt sich schon du scheinst
tiefenentspannt zu sein muss man das zum
gamen seien zum zocken
also ich würde sagen es hat seine
vorteile weil wenn man halt auf der
bühne spielt und total wirst es spielt
man hat automatisch schlechter aber auch
sonst inhalt man halte ich das reisen so
schon immer ein bisschen stress und wenn
man dann halt gar nicht mehr klar kommt
dann wirkt sich das halt auf die
performance aus
es gibt halt einige spieler die ihren
online zum beispiel extrem stark sind
und dann werden sie auf der bühne sobald
ihr auf der bühne spielen gar nicht mehr
hinbekommen als schon immer ein bisschen
traurig seitdem kein spiel klappt und
einem nicht so was seine strategie
verändert hat sich das schon positiv
ausgewirkt ist nicht mehr so der panzer
kanal in einem match gegen protoss
funktioniert dass wir zum selber gut und
nicht immer so wie gewünscht aber es
halt auch viel arbeit viel training
man kann das nicht mal so eben so
schnell machen sondern star hat dauert
und braucht seine zeit
ok dann geduld und spucke und wieder
voll
danke mehr zum thema gaming zum beispiel
mit puppen leben entwickler von edna
bricht aus jan müller-michaelis er sagt
da hat oder erzählt da hat crytek böse
geguckt weil er steht irgendwie nicht so
auf die games die die ihr lieber etwas
entwickeln und auch sehr spannend und
lustig auch wenn es einen traurigen
titel hat haudegen erzählen warum sie
manchmal weinen müssen sind aber super
jungs und wenn sie weinen dann ist das
auch irgendwie schön also jetzt wie
gesagt ich sollte einmal zeit lassen zum
entscheiden um auf eins dieser beiden
videos zu glücken klicken deswegen rege
ich jetzt einfach so lange bis der arzt
kommt
doch nicht nur diese